le pygmalion et galatée de girodet face
au radeau de la méduse ici copié par
ronger le symbole d'un affrontement
entre courants artistiques concurrents
néoclassicisme établi contre eux
romantisme naissant initialement
présentées au louvre en 1819 l'oeuvre de
jéricho bouscule les conventions de
l'époque sur ce personnage là qui a les
traits crispés qui est à moitié mort
dont on voit pas le reste du corps et
qui est bien illustrant illustrant
parfaitement bien ce qui a pu se passer
sur le radeau csn d'anthropophagie et
puis aussi une subversion parce que ils
placent en haut d'une pyramide humaine
se dire à la place la plus noble un
personnage de couleurs un tableau qui ne
laisse pas les visiteurs indifférents
est magnifique aussi concerne la ligne r
d par là le face à face entre les deux
tableaux quand même au détriment de pour
mon goût personnel au détriment de
girodet parce que c'est une posture
beaucoup plus classique sur les 1500
oeuvre du salon plus de 80 composent
l'exposition
la plupart ont été prêtées par des
musées français et étrangers une
occasion unique de les mettre en valeur
ça a permis d'identifier certaines
oeuvres qu'on qu'on ne savait plus qu'on
ne connaissait plus que les musées
n'avait pas identifiées comme avait
exposé en 1819
ça a permis aussi de faire restaurer
quelques heures donc l'agglomération
montargoise a participé à la
restauration
2 5 avr reste quelques mois pour les
admirer toutes seront exposées jusqu'au
12 janvier prochain